the attorneys general of New York and
New Jersey are now expanding their
investigations of sex abuse inside the
Roman Catholic Church this follows a
scathing grand jury report in
Pennsylvania released last month it
accused more than 300 priests of
attacking more than 1000 children
similar inquiries are underway in New
Mexico Missouri and Illinois Nicki
Bhatia spoke to four sisters who say
they were abused by the same priests
Nicki this was quite an emotional
interview that they gave you
unbelievable good morning church
officials in New York and New Jersey say
they've been cooperating with law
enforcement for some time now and
pledged to do so with their state AG's
the four sisters who are sharing their
story with the nation for the first time
say the intensifying scrutiny is overdue
murder torture every day the Fortney
Sisters Theresa patty Laura and Carolyn
say their family friend and pastor in
Pennsylvania preyed on each of them
starting in the early 1980s Carolyn was
not even 2 years old when she says
father Augustin jela began abusing her
every day of my life I think about
running my car into a pole or off of a
bridge what was the extent of your abuse
for me it's the fear of what I haven't
discovered yet because I have vivid
memories so I have moments in time when
I can't remember a thing
my niece actually found a box that had
some pornography in it and nude photos
of Carolyn their parents reported the
photos which were found in gelas
residents to the Harrisburg diocese in
1992 at the time its former bishop
William Keeler who knew about gelas
predatory behavior according to the
grand jury report was in line to become
a cardinal the Fortney say their family
was pressured to accept two settlements
from the church we all felt like we were
alone because we couldn't talk about
this because of the settlement because
of the gag order New York Attorney
General Barbara Underwood just announced
she would investigate the alleged Church
cover-ups
New Jersey Attorney General Kabir Grewal
announced a new task force to look at
the alleged abuses there nobody should
live like this with this babe but I have
hope no I do what is your hope my hope
is that the Catholic Church is no longer
silent that they will open up the
floodgates of those secret archives and
just bring justice to these people these
monsters father jela was arrested in New
Jersey in 1992 and confessed to police
but died while awaiting trial the
Harrisburg diocese apologized to the
sisters telling CBS News those in
positions of power failed to protect
children from jela a monster who preyed
on innocent children monsters right I'll
say Nicki it's so disturbing the the
first sister who said sole murdering
torture that was tough to hear their
strength is unbelievable faith is
supposed to help you not feel alone and
she said we felt like we were all alone
devastating thank you so much Nicki